if you're looking for ways to develop a
resilience to fear turn fear on itself
and practice your bravery then this
video is for you the things that most
frighten us when we actually have the
courage to do them dissolve what am I
afraid of I'm free of that I got to be
more afraid of what I'm gonna miss out
on missing out on my mission missing out
who I'm supposed to be we don't live in
a society that values bravery training
you don't really hear people saying go
out and use this day to practice
becoming fearless what's up it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
and I want to see that amazing thing
that you have inside you burst out to
have a great impact for yourself your
family your friends the community in the
world I started to believe life series
on the weekend to cover a different
person development topics that hopefully
you can absorb take some time on the
weekend to take that message in and help
you be a better version of yourself so
let's live our best believe life today
and learn how to get rid of fear enjoy
[Music]
coming up first is why you need to
develop resilience in the face of fear
with Robin Sharma if you're human you're
gonna face fear and so one of the things
that a players do that leaders without
titles do that iconic human beings do is
they develop a resilience or hardiness
in the face of fear a story I remember
reading in a in an Osho book a while ago
so there was this man and he was a
mountain climber so he climbed the
mountain and he reached the summit but
he sort of misjudged the timing and it
became dark and so he made his way down
the mountain as the Sun set but he got
to a place where it became so dark he
couldn't move and he thought he was on
this ledge and he just became paralyzed
by fear he just realized that you know
if he moved a few inches over he would
fall thousands and thousands of meters
or feet to his death and so all night
that was the most terrifying night of
his life he was on this ledge he
couldn't even move forward because they
thought he'd fall and he just stayed
there frozen for hours and hours and
hours and then with the first rays of
daylight he started laughs and the
reason he started to laugh was he
realized just below the ledge there was
this huge stone platform there was no
danger whatsoever it was just his
perception of fear that caused him to
feel terrified and I think that's a
powerful idea for us the things that
most frightened us when we actually have
the courage to do them dissolve so that
was a great intro from Robin to set
things up now let's get into how to
actually take the steps consistently to
get rid of that fear
coming up first is turn fear on itself
with Tony Robbins the only way to deal
with fear that I found in my life is a
couple ways one of those ways is to turn
it on itself and ask yourself what am I
afraid of I'm free of that I got to be
more afraid of what I'm gonna miss out
on missing out on my mission this thing
out who I'm supposed to be missing in
other words if you're not get get rid of
fear than use fair use fear or it uses
you it's that simple so you gotta say
okay what's the price if I just stay
doing this what's the price what do I
need to really even get scared if I
learn all this I don't follow through
that's something to be scared about
and then that fear will get you over
your feet it'll push you through turn
fear in itself second way you can do it
is use what you've probably heard me say
because I've used this in was 17 is my
little rocking chair test right I'm
gonna I'm gonna sit myself in my rocking
chair I'm I'm 85 years old and looking
back on my life and I say I didn't do
this or I did up next tip number two
practice bravery training with Robin
Sharma practice bravery training you
know you want to be a great footballer
we understand you've got to put in the
time to practice you want to be a great
chef we understand you've got to do the
practice you want to be a great
entrepreneur you've got to put in the
hours of rigor and discipline building
your business you want to be a great
chess champion of course they're
obsessed monomaniacal e with practice
and yet when it comes to fear we don't
live in a society that values bravery
training you don't really hear people
saying go out and use this day to
practice becoming fearless and yet you
know we all know the 10,000 hour rule we
all know the 10 year rule pioneered by
Anders Ericsson at University of Florida
the preeminent researcher in the field
of exceptional performance and that 10
year rule has now been popularized by a
lot of authors but what he found was
this if you look at any great performer
they had one thing in common
they spent the equivalent of 10 years or
10,000 hours practicing their skill
before the first signs of genius showed
up and so to become fearless why not
find some time every day to practice
becoming fearless
why not use whatever irritates you or
frustrates you or frightens you during
your day as brain for retraining so
let's say your supervisor walks in and
says you know tomorrow I'd like to give
you a you to give a presentation on that
project you did so brilliantly on and
start to pay attention you notice you
start to feel afraid develop the mindset
where you say okay I'm gonna say yes
because that is bravery training let's
say you go home and with your intimate
partner you want to speak up you want to
say something maybe you want to ask for
more love maybe you want to ask for one
of your needs to be met that because you
feel it's unmet but then you feel well
what if he or she judges me what if I
get laughed at what if they think I'm
strange develop the mindset where you
recognize that everything that scares
you is bravery training okay so what I'm
suggesting on the first insight is
really practice becoming fearless and
you will become a fearless human being
tip number three is focus on the
positives with Brendon Burchard and the
third thing that most people are
actually fearing is they're fearing what
I call outcome pain they're scared that
what if what if they lose all these
things in changing what if they go
through all this terrifying difficult
work and then the grass is not greener
the outcome is no better than I had at
the very beginning I was terrified that
with my business too I thought oh my
gosh what if I begin this business and I
do all these things and I work my butt
off but I don't make it I I don't earn
any more money I don't have a better
lifestyle
I don't grow as fast what if on the
other side of the fence it's not any
better and we sit and we think what if
it's not better and I would have to go
through all that and if we're stuck
there thinking that way we never change
so part of the maturity in the mastery
of life is realizing too that instead of
focusing on the outcomes that are
negative we can start thinking and
dreaming about and visualizing and
really give
our attention our focus and powers of
attraction into those things that would
be powerful and good and satisfied
fulfilling happy joyous on the other
side of that fence the things that would
turn out to be wonderful and magnificent
if we change their life I if I quit the
smoking I'm finally gonna be able to
feel good again I'm not gonna have to be
addicted to some small little thing
that's killing millions of people that's
just feeding these huge organizations
that are killing people over and over
and over again I'm not gonna pet you
eight a disease in my body or in my
family I'm not gonna make my everybody
carry on my addictions oh you know what
in that new area - I'm gonna feel fit
and happy and vibrant and energized on
my own again
oh when I start that diet you know what
I'm gonna really enjoy tasting some new
foods because I've tasted good food for
a long time I'm going to actually enjoy
going out with people again I'm gonna
enjoy shopping again to find clothes
actually fit my body you start thinking
about all the things that will be
positive from that change and when you
do that you start to master your mind
and direct it better because you know
what when you're obsessing about loss
pain process pain and outcome pain guess
what the more you focus on those the
more you obsess about those types of
pain your brain and your body goes no
don't do that I don't want to experience
that because we built and we've been
gifted with this incredible contraption
here that is unbelievably driven to
avoid pain and when we realize that then
we have to stop suffering in our mind
and stewing in our mind about the pain
we might experience if we do the very
things that would improve our lives tip
number four is step into the fear with
me here's what I think happens to most
people there's some opportunity that
comes along there's some moment that
comes along with this with a client or
meeting somebody or an event something
comes along that you're afraid of you're
afraid of doing it it's gonna stretch
you beyond we've ever done before and
then what you do is you rationalize
saying no I don't have the money to go
to that event I'm too busy to go and do
that thing right now you find the reason
why you can't go and do it you
rationalize it but really deep down the
reason is you're just afraid
and until you spot the fear until you
understand that it's really just the
fear then you're never gonna solve the
problem so step one is understanding
when there is fear
step two is then stepping into it and
doing it anyway and a lot of this stuff
is just so subconscious you know we as
human beings are kind of trained to when
we're afraid something's gonna go wrong
and to be safe and so it's trying to
catch that subconscious action and
proactively change it so as an example
for me when I was starting my youtube
channel my agent would tell me you have
to go out and do videos in public I want
you to go out on the street I make your
video in public my natural reaction was
fear but I didn't catch it initially it
was the gear won't be as good in public
you know I can't control the light
settings I'm gonna be bouncing around
with the camera it's not gonna be a
great experience for the people watching
why would I do that
I'm rationalizing a reason why I don't
have to do it we're really I'm just
afraid right you could solve all those
problems and he told me stop being
afraid and just go out and do it he got
through it and let me see my own fear
and so I did it and when I first went
out and filmed in public I took out it
was my phone or my camera I don't
remember and I'm walking on the street
and then the postman is there and so as
soon as I see the postman I quiet down I
can put the camera away
just walking normally and then when the
postman leaves I'm back to filming and
that time I know it it's like I'm I'm
doing it because I'm afraid and I got
pissed okay next time
I got a Speak Up next time I gotta do
better and so I went out and forced us
up to go and do it again and I was
walking past and there were these
construction workers and instantly again
the the panic sets in like people are
watching the construction workers like I
know they don't really even care about
me what I'm saying what's happening on
the street but I forced myself through
it it was awkward it wasn't great I
think I had to redo it again anyway
but I
the step I got better at it I recognized
the fear and I jumped into it and now to
the point where I'll make videos walking
down the hall I make videos when I'm at
Disneyland Disneyworld you know I'll
make videos in the streets of anywhere
and there's still a moment even now
after how many videos I've done there's
still a moment of who's watching I think
it's natural normal it's not as strong
as it used to be and more importantly it
doesn't limit me from doing the things
that I want to do and so spotting the
fear and not rationalizing it away and
not just doing what your subconscious
always does that keeps you down where
you are is so important being truthful
that the reason why you said no or
you're not taking this opportunity is
just because you're afraid and the
answer to say no should never be because
I'm afraid you want to reject your
system so whenever that's the answer
because I'm afraid to do it now you have
to do it because you're afraid now you
have to go and do it and you build your
muscle that gets stronger and take on
new opportunities so you don't play safe
and play small for the rest of your life
and tip number five is grandiose your
way out of fear with Quentin Tarantino
when you experience moments of
self-doubt how do you approach getting
out of that dark place good question
I grandiose my way out of fear if you
can imagine that it's a good it's like
literally it's like okay I'm gonna do
one of the greatest car chases of all
time and if I don't I'm not as talented
as I thought I was and I will realize
that there is a ceiling to my talent
right now I don't think there is but if
I don't do but if it's not one of the
greatest car chases of all time that I
failed and I there is a ceiling in my
talent I'm not as good as I thought I
was and I said that to everybody and was
I scared yeah you're right
I had trepidation going all because it's
mine to fail and it's Maya Nubia and
it's failing in front of the mirror too
cuz I don't know if I did it or not and
I'll be like okay yeah you are not as
good as you thought you were and that
got me to Mount Everest if it's true
everyone point he goes Robert can you
imagine you and me doing this car chase
together how great it's gonna be in a
mic game you're on your own brother kids
hundred mile an hour Bulls you want to
live the vanishing point dream buddy
live it he did it all by himself and I'm
so impressed
so thank you guys so much for watching
I'd love to know what was your favorite
clip and why what are you going to apply
immediately somehow to help you fight
the fears that are in front of you leave
it down the comments below for me it was
Tony Robbins the how tip number one the
rocking-chair test it's still something
that I use on a regular basis anytime
that I am too afraid of something I just
make the future fear bigger that fear of
regret for decades looking back on my
life bigger than the immediate fear that
I have right now so that pain is just so
large so the pain of the immediate fear
of your finger nails hurting I punch
myself in the arm with that bigger fear
of regret so I don't feel this pain
anymore because I have this huge pain
here and it forces me to take immediate
action so that was my favorite clip I
love to know what was yours and why and
how are you going to start making an
immediate change in your life let me
know leave in the comments below I'm
looking forward to hearing from you I
also want to give a quick charter to
clyde haze Clyde thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and doing the Instagram post on it
really appreciate the support men and
I'm so glad you enjoyed the book so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love see you soon
I was reminded this morning of a
question I'm often asked how do you
eliminate theater from your life and you
know I don't think you ever do I think
you become courageous you see courageous
people are not people without their
courageous people are people that face
the things they fear there's no courage
without fear whenever you go to do
something that you've never done before
fear is going to step in now some people
are afraid of flying people are afraid
of different things that can make them
very very uncomfortable if they don't
get over that fear well I was afraid of
flying one day I was flying somewhere
and I wasn't very comfortable I was
sitting on the plane there was a guy
sitting beside me he was very laid-back
reading one leg up over the other
reading his newspaper and we hit some
rough weather I'm gonna tell you it got
turbulent that plane was bouncing all
over the place
this guy is there holding his paper and
he never never skipped a breath I was
gripping onto the seats and he just kept
reading when the flake finally smoothed
out I looked over at him and I hadn't
even spoken to him up until that point
and I said pardon me how come you
weren't scared back there he smiles and
he said well he said I fly these things
in fact I train people to fly these
things I said you know I can't
understand why this plane doesn't fall
right out of the sky I mean either ride
doesn't go straight down he started to
laugh and he said you can fly a rock if
you've got enough thrust behind it when
he said that I could see myself throwing
a rock and the rock was flying you never
think of a rock flying when you throw it
but the rock was flying as long as
there's thrust the rock will fly then
they got to thinking there's millions of
pounds of thrust in these big engines
did you know something I've never been
uncomfortable since if we're afraid of
something it
we don't understand it theory is caused
by ignorance the unknown but when you
understand that you know your leaves
don't study the principle of light see
how the air is wrapped around the wings
it's wrapped around the wings
it holds the plane up there don't permit
fear to control your life absolutely
refused to someone said fear knocked on
the door faith open it there was low
there was no one there you see you
eliminate fear through intelligent
action face the thing you fear and there
will leave you I won't permit fear to
control my life
not even for five minutes I used to let
fear control me all the time almost all
the time
fears caused by the unknown if there's
something you're afraid of go study it
understand it talk to someone who's a
professional in that particular area but
for goodness sake don't let it control
your life anymore think of the people
that are afraid to go into their own
business they're afraid to move to the
place they'd really like to go
they're afraid to ask the girl or the
guy for a date what are they doing their
life is drying up it's shrinking we're
only here for a short time make it a
good time get rid of the fear face it
raise your standard Apple at the pool
its core values
is that we believe that people who
passion can change the way people now
one drop of myself work depends on
Europe it's supposed to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details